[Music]
you're a big Halloween fan I think we
actually talked about this once years
ago you love Halloween you take it very
my favorite holiday absolutely and you
like to make your own costumes yeah it
doesn't feel right unless I kind of do
it myself that's true good for you heard
of creativity what kind of costumes are
we talking about
I mean well my rule in general so I
don't drive myself crazy is that I have
to conceive of and execute the entire
costume all on the day of Halloween
really I don't do any I don't do any
planning I come up with something or
like oh look I have a fork I'll make
something out of this like so the
costume could end up being really
brilliant or horrible and sometimes it
is horrible sometimes it consists of you
know a fork taped to some newspaper
that's wrapped around my head like and
people are like what are you and I'm
like I have a fork on my head I went
through a series where I was just colors
like one year I was blue and then the
next year I was red it's you can go to
Kmart and just buy everything there that
you can find this one color and put it
all on and paint your face and then you
say I am red I'm red and that's it it
tends to be a conversation stopper
yeah slam no candy all right we have it
with this photo I don't know me this is
you and a French made tab that was last
Halloween yeah that was it thank you
[Applause]
every night I sort of broke my own rule
because I was doing a show that
Halloween why did I do this thing called
hit record and we had a show on
Halloween I was in New York and I came
out as a as a french maid very nice yes
thank you I've always wanted to wear
that outfit just I haven't thought of a
an excuse yet
especially not outdoors I want to ask
you about a movie that I am I'm obsessed
with which is the Lincoln movie that
that I know that you are in yeah it's
Steven Spielberg's take on Abraham lean
into the Civil War period very into this
period and and of course Daniel
day-lewis in this film plays Lincoln who
play his eldest son Robert Robert what's
it like I'm just Daniel day-lewis is
such a fascinating character to me what
was it like to act with him what's his
process like because I've heard he's
method did he become Lincoln he kind of
did I mean he's not silly about it you
know he knows that you're on a movie set
and whatever but he does he does stay
like talking in that voice he spent a
year coming up with how he wanted the
voice to sound and he doesn't
I never heard his voice and I never
called him Daniel until I was lucky
enough to be there on the last day of
shooting and so I got to watch him shed
the character so interesting to me so he
would talk as Lincoln and you would all
address him as what mr. president Steven
Spielberg yes would be like mr.
president can you take a step to the
left yep
I would just say sir because he was my
dad right yeah that's fascinating to me
yeah well I mean again he's not like
silly about it right you know he'll
he'll you know chat or make jokes in
between takes or whatever but but as
Lincoln kind of kind of like you
wouldn't you wouldn't want to like go up
to him and be like you know oh did you
see you know
did you see the Avengers or whatever
like you know he wouldn't probably
that's exactly oh so that is all I've
been doing the whole time I'd be like
look at airplane
what witchcraft is this but now I'd like
it yeah if there's like a painting on
the wall or something you'd be down to
talk about like oh look at that you know
or something sure he wasn't silly about
it but he definitely he's really focused
and you are going to play you're when
the movie comes out you will be his
eldest son Robert he had a strained kind
of relations right well he was kind of
an absent father
yeah and that's that's that's a cool
thing about this movie is you know
Abraham Lincoln is such an icon in
American culture up on Mount Rushmore on
our $5 bill we turn him into this hero
that's kind of absolute angel and he was
a human being like every other human
being and I really admire Stephen for
taking the approach with this movie and
painting him as a human being somebody
who had to make compromises who was
being told that he was bad person from
all sides of the spectrum and all he was
trying to do I mean he the the movies
about the month leading up to the
passing of the 13th amendment that
banned slavery and he had to make all
sorts of moves and do all sorts of like
questionable things yeah to pass they
had to make a lot of compromises yeah
and his own that you said his own
personal life was relationship with his
eldest son not perfect yeah exactly